president-elect Donald Trump says
ExxonMobil chairman and CEO will be his
Secretary of State
mr. Trump announced this morning that it
will nominate Rex Tillerson as the
country's next top diplomat the decision
ends a very public search process
Tillison could face a confirmation fight
because of his ties to Russian President
Vladimir Putin the president-elect said
on Twitter this morning that Tillerson
is one of the truly great business
leaders of the world mr. Trump has also
decided that former Texas Governor Rick
Perry will be his Secretary of Energy
Nancy Cordes is watching the transition
for us Nancy good morning good morning
Tillerson has spent his entire career
more than four decades at Exxon Mobil so
he has vast experience doing business
with foreign governments including
Russia and that has already been met
with some criticism from those inside
and outside his party at age 64 Rex
Tillerson has headed the world's largest
publicly-traded oil company for nearly a
decade last year he was ranked number 25
on Forbes list of the most powerful
people under Tillerson 's leadership
Exxon Mobil struck a deal with Russia in
2011 to begin drilling for oil in the
Arctic but the project was halted three
years later by Western sanctions after
Russia invaded Crimea I'm gonna comply
with the sanctions there's not any
conversation otherwise about that
Tillerson said earlier this year that
his relationships with foreign
governments including Russia's are
strictly business I'm not here to
represent the United States government's
interest I'm not here to defend it nor
am I here to criticize it that's that's
not what I do I'm a businessman but if
confirmed a Secretary of State Tillerson
will be America's top diplomat
representing US foreign policy interests
and will need to navigate his 15-year
history with Vladimir Putin I have a
very close relationship with him I don't
agree with everything he's doing Putin
awarded Tillerson a Russian order of
friendship in 2013 that same year
Tillerson spoke to Charlie Rose about
how he handles international
negotiations you have to
look the head of state of that country
eyeball to eyeball and say to them I'm
going to make this commitment now I'm
counting on you to meet your commitments
for Secretary of Energy mr. Trump has
settled on former Texas Governor Rick
Perry the two-time presidential
candidate once proposed eliminating the
Energy Department though it famously
slipped his mind at a 2011 debate the
third agency of government I would I
would do away with the education the
Commerce and let's see
I can't the third one I can't sorry oops
with those two positions filled mr.
Trump is now pretty close to completing
his cabinet the president-elect hasn't
held an official press conference since
he was a candidate back in July and late
yesterday he postponed his highly
anticipated press conference set for
this Thursday where he was slated to
explain how he's going to handle
potential business conflicts gale his
aides say the lawyers need a little more
time to work out the details and that
he'll hold that press conference early
in January all right thank you very much
Nancy